whenever I stay at a White Lotus I
always have a memorable time always
welcome to the White Lotus in Sicily
[Music]
you guys are here to learn about your
Sicilian Roots sounds like a fun boys
trip it wasn't supposed to be a boys
trip or a family vacation right now and
it's just the three of us because all
the women in our family hate you please
can we just drop it okay so first of all
my producer ran into at a restaurant
last week called horses very good and
you impromptu did an impression of
Jennifer so I would love no I I
can you do that
what did you do invitation of me yeah I
did I can't remember how I did it but it
was it was voted can you give me a
glimmer of it oh I well I
am in the mood right now
that was it that was it
can you do him
um let's see um oh boy let's see that's
the pressure's on
my character's not defined enough let's
see okay wait all right just talk some
more and I'm just gonna naturally do it
okay to say something who you want me to
talk oh you talk no no you know I would
ask you a question okay you too have
some incredible scenes together this
season I mean you've even talked
yourselves from season one the sex scene
between the two of you in the first
episode I'm wondering like it's the best
use of a foot I've ever seen in foreplay
I'm wondering how much of that was
improv I want to know that that was an
improv did you do something with your
foot I think you did if I've not missed
it was it you took his you took his foot
and you put it
yeah I don't even remember that that was
so long ago I I think I did I think that
was right yeah I did how you know what
you know Tanya's weird see I can't you
gotta stop blaming Grace it's not even
sexy that's not even sexy it was it was
it was really hot it was gorgeous but
did you the two of you do play do you
improv a lot I mean if you can remember
that scene well we actually had sex
okay hahaha
Why didn't it not seem like it it
absolutely did 100 did I just borrowed
from you because that's what she said
earlier
oh you know
I don't know I mean there's faking sex
and then there's just doing it and then
like not talking about it you know what
I mean like
[Laughter]
I mean like no one knows really no
except the people that are 10 feet away
um
said
everything did you say that yeah that's
so cute
um so I don't know if you heard last
season there was a lot of chatter online
about who the most heinous character and
who the nicest character in season one
is so I want the two of you to weigh in
who is the nicest character in season
two in the most heinous probably Adam is
the nicest he's the sweetest kid
character not the people
I'll be Alby is the sweetest boy yeah I
I you know and I have to say I I agree
with that I agree with yeah he was
probably the nicest of all yeah it's a
sweetheart and who's the most heinous
some people are saying Greg I'm I'm
gonna neither confirm nor deny no I
don't I don't really am I am I heinous
do you think
yeah you know I really like that you
said that
Greg is heinous
Uranus
die I've always wanted to know Jennifer
I think Mike said when he wrote this
show he basically wrote it off a trip
you took to Africa together and you were
sharing or you were in separate tents
oh no we were no we were in we were in
beds next to each other in the tent I'm
talking about Mike was six inches away
so what did you do on that trip
that inspired this entire incredible
show that we have what is your vacation
style
you know
I have to say Mike White was a very good
sport because
I mean I don't think he thought it
through I don't think he thought it
through that he would be that close to
me in the tent like he would have to be
you know literally you know listen to my
breathing and stuff and then of course I
have insomnia so he would have to like
keep waking up and I'd be like alive
next to him you know what I mean and I
think that would was probably scary but
we both love animals that's why he
invited me and um
um I guess you know
I think he sort of you know we had a
great time but I think he sort of saw I
was kind of weird and I think he thought
that was funny that I was kind of like
you know my fear of snakes and but also
um you know I don't go to bed I don't
sleep I thought he think he I think he
thought that was weird and I don't know
he just took every weird thing about me
and made it into Tanya I think or
something you know but a more extreme
version if I was Tanya I wouldn't never
date again I would never be able to date
anybody but you know me saw a weird
thing going on and he wrote it and thank
God because I guess
um look at this look where you are yeah
it was that was how was your how has
your phone changed since that Emmy has
it like personally professionally how
many more calls what how would the calls
change how has your life changed and how
are both of your lives changed since the
show
well
mine I I mean you know people wave at me
when I walk down the street you know
they go like this now after this season
they might go like that but who knows
you know
um
you know yeah it's all good it's all
like everybody you know uh I think you
know it's sort of weird you're if you're
on this train of like a cool thing that
people like they sort of
if they never liked you before or never
said hello it just I like that I don't
care what made them change I just like
that they're staying high now you know I
mean you know I mean people I knew like
you know neighbors that are like you
know speaking to me for the first time
you know that we're sort of always sort
of you know
kind of not very fuzzy all of a sudden
they're like hey
yeah it's Tanya you know sometimes
people call me my name sorry it's good
you know it was all great what a what a
lucky thing you know I know it's it's
just this little moment in my life and
and it's going to change and there'll be
other people who are having good moments
and stuff and but I have to say I really
am very grateful and I I'm really
enjoying it
this new whatever this you know fun like
being considered you know for something
other than a limited you know just what
I've done you know yeah
I think it's such a nice thing to see
that that I love the role you know I
love the role like when I read the first
season
you know my my I don't know my relatable
characters were Tanya
Armand and Fred's character of Quinn
they were my like real touchstones
uh I just love seeing that that
character has become so in front of
because I love all your work I do I'm a
big fan I've always been but I mean
really I just think that this is such a
quintessentially
important character for you I do and I
just think it's so good
and I'm looking at me I'm the guy who
gets to be just like bathed in a little
bit of that glow and I get to fake sex
with Uncle Rico
now that he's loaded I think he regrets
marrying such a dud what is going on
with you there's a reason they invited
us here it's like you sold your company
you got rich and now he's your best
friend are these the kind of people
we're gonna be hanging out with now did
you vote babe be honest I did
good night so I wanted to ask both of
you what sort of decisions did you make
as a couple or sort of on your own about
your backstory like what makes the two
these two so perfect for each other and
what makes them your grinning already
hungry what makes them so wrong for each
other
I mean well one thing we decided was
just how long they've been together
right so we talked about seven eight
years they've been married
um that was important to establish
because you know really when you've been
married for a long time your
relationship is you know you have
different issues than if you've like
newlyweds so that was one thing and I
think I think we also decided that
they'd met at
um a wedding
oh yeah
yes they met at a wedding okay
and why are they why are they perfect
for each other and maybe not so much
well
it's what it's a big question it's a
good question I think I mean I think
they're very I think they're very
compatible I think they they kind of
like intellectually are on the same
level they have common interests and
um you know but I think maybe I think
they're you know they're flawed it's
like opposites attracts sometimes too
you know and I don't know well I mean I
guess maybe like they're almost what's
not helpful at the beginning is it
almost that they are so open with each
other about everything it's almost like
there's a
yeah maybe like even the sexy talk
in the sexy
talked very much like that
um
I know for you that Mike Mike very much
wrote this for you and you said that
this was a very personal role for you
and very difficult yeah in a way yeah um
because it was most like you maybe any
character you've ever played if you want
to talk a little bit about it well I
think what I meant by that was like I
yeah Mike Mike and I have been friends
for a really long time and I think he
you know he he knows kind of the more
vulnerable side of me and things like
that so I think that was just something
that I think he kind of had in his back
pocket when he wrote Harper and
um and I think every thing is difficult
for me I mean to be honest like every
part that I play is like I find
everything difficult because I take it
so I just take it I don't know I just
really let it kind of wash over me so
but I felt very I felt like I very very
much related to Harper
um in a lot of ways so it felt a little
bit closer to home as opposed to like
some characters that I played you know
I've played you know serial killers and
criminals and I just haven't you know I
haven't of course I relate to those
characters too but just not as much as
just like you know like a just like a
woman like Harper who's like a
professional kind of you know
intelligent married woman with no kids
to add some levity to it though I think
your character spends more time in a
bathrobe than anybody was that a plus
filming in a bathrobe honestly that was
a zombie baby that was all me was it yes
of course I was like put that get that
robe on me in fact I forgot to steal it
off the set that just reminded me I want
to buy that robe me too or steal it I
know was there any significance to the
green necklace because she wears it in
every scene did you make it that
personal for you anyway or was that just
a wardrobe Cho
um no everything was personal
um yeah that was like you know the
Keepsake you know from Harper's mom but
thank you for noticing so well I I know
that you've talked a little bit about
how the two couples together those are
some of my favorite scenes in the entire
season is just watching the two couples
sit together whether they're having
breakfast or lunch and just that one
upmanship and the contrarian that she is
so will I think you've called it like a
spider's web
yes can you kind of elaborate like what
kinetically happens between the four
people when they get together can you
break down the spider's web
um well I mean I guess what's great
about the situation that Mike's created
is that you have tensions within each
couple but also across the table you
know like across the couples
um and I mean exactly what is going on
between the more like changes from
episode to episode as the series goes on
but I think all I meant by that was just
that it is deliciously complex
I love that not that I would eat a spy
this way
when did you both find out like how does
Mike present the series to you do you
find out the ending
in the beginning are you given the
scripts are you given everybody's part
is it something you wanted or you don't
want to know
I personally wanted to know
um I hate you know I hate not knowing
because I would I want to know like what
my journey is as a character where I
start and where I end up so that I can
you know track every moment and feel
like every moment is is real
um so I treat it kind of like a long
movie like a seven hour movie and we got
them pretty early on I think that that's
rare for TV shows normally you're just
waiting and you shoot and then you wait
for the next group to come in but we got
them pretty early on so we could kind of
we kind of knew where we were going
which was good but we shot out of order
so it was necessary it was necessary for
us to know because we did not shoot in
order
um I don't know if you guys are aware of
online in the first season there was so
much conversation about audiences
ranking who the most heinous character
was and the nicest character was so in
both of your opinions who's the most
heinous and the nicest character of
season two
um heinous I'm gonna go with
um Cameron just just as the true Harper
that I am I'm just gonna go right just
go right there right for the jugular
Cameron heinous I'll be seems very nice
Alby is the nicest I agree with this
Albie must be protected at all costs we
must protect the audience protect his
innocent innocent boyish smile and will
who's the most heinous
I mean I I guess I would go with Cameron
too
um yeah and I'd say I'll be
that's what my friend does yeah and my
last question to you is I don't know the
mirror scene and I don't want to give
anything away because I think people
should not know but do you think that
was intentional or not intentional on
his part as an actor or as a character
both
um as an actor as me totally intentional
um as a character I think Harper
see I think this is the beginning to
Harper starting to question herself
because I think on first you know glance
of what she glances
um I think she you know would think like
oh God he's totally doing this on
purpose but but actually then I think
there's a moment where she's like you
know what maybe this is just we're in
Italy people get naked in front of each
other big deal maybe I need to loosen up
you know what I mean yeah so I think she
goes through stages of of things I've
seen a lot of guys who like make all
this money and they just start acting
different you guys party
that's fun that's fun so the first
question I have for both of you and
congratulations on an amazing amazing
season is I don't know if you're aware
that last season there was a lot of
discussion online
um articles written about who the most
heinous characters are and who are the
nicest characters and people would
debate so for the two of you who do you
think the most heinous character is and
the nicest character in season two
interesting question
um
penis is like anus is intense
um it's funny because you you play them
and even if they're of hiring characters
you want to find something likeable in
them because that's how you make them as
real as possible so you know you're kind
of weirdly protective about your own
heinous character but um I would say I
mean Adam is Adam's character Alby is
the purest right I agree with you
remember but maybe he's yeah and but I
do think uh Megan's character is messed
up as she is she also is the most
heinous is the most heinous is a good
person
um most heinous uh Cameron's pretty
heinous but then who else is pretty well
speaking of yourself mate yeah because I
have to tell you Aubry and wilbo said
you really not you as a person
yeah yeah yeah
um I mean he's pretty yeah he's
manipulative he's a sociopath um but
also we haven't seen the episodes it'd
be interesting to see how because Mike
likes to evolve things in the edit so
it'd be interesting oh wow I mean
actually heinous if you think about
John's character I was gonna say that
he's pretty horrendous pretty bad yeah I
can't wait to see the rest of it because
I've watched every episode three times
already it's like I mean I need more
already anymore already I know that you
auditioned for season one I did so how
did you get that call like how was the
call because I would assume you didn't
have to audition for season two that
Mike sort of Rights Mike tends to write
four people yes no
um I certainly audition no you did okay
um I so yeah I got an audition from my
agent and I made a tape
and
um you know I've said that like as soon
as I got the email I was just like
immediately devastated because I just
felt like it was so it was so unlikely
that it would end up being
um me that they picked so
um I think we both kind of were such big
fans of the first season and we're just
like still kind of pinching ourselves
that we're even
you know here so yeah what's the call
like because I know you said maybe you
said that you never thought it would
happen either I thought you were both
yeah no no God no no I was already
saying before cursing the person that
was going to get the part you know
whoever that [ __ ]
um yeah it was uh yeah and again you
know it's interesting with White Lotus
because it was quite unexpected wasn't
it there wasn't a huge amount of fanfare
and then so it was a very organic
experience to enjoy it so yeah I was
like everyone else just kind of watching
the first episode thinking this is a
nice escapism and then evolving into
something really
special so um it was pretty surreal and
then for it to be in
um in Sicily it was very surreal and the
design of the show is that we stay in
the most beautiful places because we're
supposed to be Uber Rich so yeah you
know these places where you had to pinch
yourself and and you know think it
doesn't get much better the mirror scene
I had I asked Aubry from her character's
perspective was it and I don't want to
give anything away because I think
audiences should experience that scene
but was it intentional in his part that
he's in front of the mirror and she sees
him
I think he uh
probably more calculating than he first
gives off yeah but he uh you know there
was a there was I've said before but
they originally we shot it and it was a
bit more it was more intense than
miracene it was more you know
but I think when we were shooting it it
felt a bit much so Mike wanted to it has
to be on the boundary of life was it
just accidental he's kind of a it
doesn't give a guy and he's just wiping
his clothes off or is it quite
deliberate to create something from her
character and I you have to see but I
think it is on the latter
I think it was very cool that you got to
be kind of like what I call like in
horror movies it's like the final girl
but you're the girl that's in the first
scene which means that you survive and
it was so iconic in the first season and
there's so many elements of it that are
similar but different just sort of for
you as an actor is filming that scene
um and then as a girl I'm just thinking
to myself like how many takes was it
because your hair was completely perfect
and you dive in the water
yeah I mean we did it for a long time uh
that day and I think we decided early on
that I would only get
some of my hair wet like the top of it I
didn't fully submerge
um but you had a certain point you just
kind of like you know you get wet and
you're like I guess we're dealing with
with this amount of wetness now because
you just can't go back but um but that
was really fun and like a fun fact is
that the two women on the other beach
chairs in the first scene with me were
cast members on Survivor with Mike stop
it yeah
Cara and Angelina wow so people who are
Survivor fans are definitely very good
they were great so for the two of you
how did you infuse the reveal is it
something that you're given the script
and you go through it and you find out
who did it are you given everybody's
Parts how does Mike present to you sort
of the ending of it we have all the
scripts you know it it's
it's not really us you know Mike is so
such a genius you know that he uh that
sounds cringe to me saying that [ __ ]
your Genius but no but he's so very true
it's who it is and he's amazing at what
he does how he writes and then how he
constructs a story so we're there to Aid
him but it's his obviously everything
about it is his story it's his
everything in the tone you know
um so there's there's not a way for us
to infuse it because Mike's already
found that you know honestly so in the
show both your characters or your both
couples that you spend you know you
spend your time with
um Aubry and Will's characters are kind
of having this one-upmanship about who
has the better relationship so defend
your cause why do you think the two of
you have the better relationship than
the other couple on the series
uh I think they love each other and they
have true chemistry and they have you
know great physical life sexually
together after having many kids I I
think there's joy there yeah the play
which I think is yeah this is nice
there's some
you know truth issues both ways that go
as you find out more and more as the
season goes on it gets really [ __ ] up
but
um yeah I mean they they there's true
Joy there whereas you know the the other
couple are there's love definitely loved
it but I think they find it harder to
just enjoy life
um last question you've you've teased a
little bit how Sinister and sexy this is
compared to the first season so give us
a final tease of what we can expect
because I've seen the first five
episodes and I have no clue where it's
going but it's already by episode three
or four things get going in a major yeah
yeah
oh man I mean it's hard for me to even
remember what those last couple of
episodes are because we shot everything
at the same time out of order so they're
not in my head as like little
chapters
um but I don't know what would you say
like
your expectations will be
blown
that's such a generic thing
well
the the least expected thing is the
thing that happened
did anybody figure it out did either of
you figure it out when you read no no
you had no idea no
because I actually was like
yeah because he tees up every storyline
so so but even in episode seven every
storyline is building to a climax but
you just don't know it really could be
anybody I think is the sort of the point
yeah yeah
flirting is one of the pleasures of life
you're 80 years old but the women I
desire remain young you can relate to
that
there is a debate in one of the scenes
that you both play in about the
Godfather being the greatest American
movie of all time settle the debate is
it the greatest American movie of all
time and if not what is
it's certainly a great movie there's no
question about that
greatest I don't know pretty up there
I'd like to
I still like Citizen Kane a lot
but uh I also like eight and a half you
know it's a great movie uh lots of them
you like al-modovar no yeah but America
you say that America oh America I would
say well that's up there I mean The
Wizard of Oz is up there oh absolutely
Wizard of Oz Casablanca yeah wow those
are those are good ones
um
so I don't know and the Godfather's up
there though definitely you know what's
in my top three what the grand
the grandpa oh isn't that a good movie
stopped making that that
great experience that one is ranks with
uh as for experiences with Wes Anderson
with this one
really absolutely it's much the same
mentality of of gathering together
people in a family and having as much a
good time it was the same feeling he's
wonderful to work for both of these men
so if you had to spend a week at the
Grand Budapest Hotel or at the White
Lotus as a person no no no no no no no I
would be six months there okay
no Sicily baby Sicily baby Sicily all
the way great answer this is an
incredible second season and what I
learned is you can tell me if I'm wrong
is that Mike told you that this is
basically based on this story between
this Father's son taking a trip together
it's based on his own life Loosely based
Lucy just he took his dad to Sweden
where their family was from
um
the rest is invention all the Intrigue
and all the kind of you know craziness
that's going on between us
um and he didn't go with his son you
know it was just you know the the father
and not the grandson
um but I think it got him thinking about
oh that's kind of a cool idea for a
story for White Lotus is you know this
family tracing their roots and and
ancestry and stuff in the Homeland now I
saw one of the other actors on the show
posted a video of the two of you
together and I think it was on your
birthday and this was a behind the
scenes and the two of you seem to have
really really created this incredible
Bond
on on screen and off screen can you talk
a little bit about that it just was a a
gift
we became friends instantly
and uh
I'm uh
what more can I say so yeah friendships
uh
I don't want to carry on too much it
might burst into tears
it's a gift when you get a friend it
really really is and I feel that way
about Michael and his wife we've became
a kind of a trio wonderful people uh I
don't want to carry on too much but uh
it's true I can't believe there was a
tape made of that birthday party but uh
I suppose it's okay it doesn't matter
but it was his birthday she gave a big
party for him and she asked me to make a
speech and I did
it was a spontaneous speech right from
my heart
and we've remained friends
so I know that I'm glad it comes through
because it does because I believe that
comes through in the camera yes
generally and I think that included in
that family feeling is Adam yeah yeah I
think that you can see our affection for
each other and our respect
I'm wondering for you your character you
play a producer but they don't really
talk about what kind of things he
produces did you as a as an actor make
that decision in your head is he
producing some really high brow stuff
does he do like superhero movies like
what is he producing well he makes a
reference to and he's like it's not like
the he's talking about the governor this
is not like that kind of garbage you do
that Superhero junk or whatever so
obviously he's you know
Dominic's done some big Blockbuster
stuff but I think he's also
uh done some you know stuff that he
thought was more artistic
um as well that's at least my vision of
him
but not received that way necessarily
um maybe not but maybe as well you know
uh
I think he's done very well
you know that's why you can afford three
rooms at the White Lotus I was going to
say two weeks he's got a lot of money
yeah he's done he's done pretty well in
Hollywood well American movies I I want
to say uh pads of Glory I think it's a
great movie I wanted to mention Kubrick
one of the grades yeah one of the grades
there's a phone call
in the first episode and your wife is
screaming at you on the phone yeah who
is actually screaming at you on the day
how did that go
I think it was Kiara Reddit for me oh
really yeah I think it was one of our uh
I didn't know I didn't know one of our
friends
um
uh yeah that's an interesting question
obviously whoever was worked
as you really came through but I love
that your face didn't move but it said
everything
because that's real life that's how we
really react that's how that's the
Brilliance can you say there's nothing
to say it's called a superior actor
that's what that means speaking of
superior actors you have an Oscar statue
tell me if this is true or not that you
bring it to set when you do plays and if
so did you bring it to the White Lotus
set is it hidden no no it's only on it's
only in place only in place yeah it's
not hidden in like the the head or
anything like that I don't know
what were you both like at alby's age
the character I'll be oh God
he seems so together
I was out of my mind
yeah me too it's in the mid 60s in in
L.A I mean you know those are crazy
times before you were born forget about
it bless bless your heart
oh as Ilya read the wife with me really
Ilya was one of our producer's
assistants and she read uh she read the
wife that's right off camera I asked for
her to do that because I wanted rather
than just a sometimes it'll be the
script supervisor good for you but uh I
thought Elliot would have done a good
job and she did so that was good I
wonder if you can both speak too Mike is
obvious incredible at what he does both
seasons are just phenomenal and they're
so true and we see all of ourselves in
every single character
pretty neat trick it's a pretty neat
trick I'm wondering because you've both
done so many projects how is Mike's
style as a director I know you said
before that when you take on projects
you get those lines down to the point
where they're part of your soul so
infusing those ingenious lines and sort
of how does he work as a director that's
sort of different than the way you've
worked before it comes to the set
with this
solid
positive energy it's not frenetic it's
just simply healthy
and he's ready to have a good time
as he has such faith in you has faith in
them he has faith in the material and
we're going to make something really
good and what do you want to what do you
want to show me show me what you got
it just makes you want to do anything
do your best and if it doesn't quite
work we'll try this we'll try this try a
different line try this
I can't say enough about him
yeah and he's very kind and to everybody
on the crew
um yeah and generous you know he you can
you can feel
comfortable enough to come up with ideas
you know there's not there's not that
tension that's on the set
um
and that's that's really important you
know also is it this is the first time I
shot a TV show like a movie you know
when you shoot TV you shoot episode one
and then you do episode two then you do
three
this was you know scheduled like a movie
more by locations
um like a seven hour movie and that was
really fun for me I really enjoyed that
did you know in the beginning who did it
are you told in the beginning do you
read the whole script do you only read
your part how do you find out
or do you not know
or was it you but
a way to find out as an actor actor oh I
don't want to know obviously but I want
to know when you find out
I haven't seen them all yet so you don't
know
I'll leave it on that juice
you know the juicy suspenseful
and you really did your homework thanks
a lot you bring your assistant to a
vacation with your husband it's not like
she's gonna be in our bed and stuff I
don't know what's going on with Greg
but I think it's bullet I think he's
having an affair so I've been asking a
lot of the cast today in the first
season there was a lot of online
conversation about who the most heinous
character was and who the nicest
character was and people were sort of
like had their
you know at their debate so this season
who do you think the nicest best
character is in the most hands
I'll be the nicest it might be the least
controversial for sure alby's pure you
mean well he does mean well do you think
you mean well I think the most heinous
maybe Greg
or or yeah he's he's not very nice he's
not treating him that nice there's some
right yeah or
who would you say
um yeah Greg yeah I've been telling
everybody that Alby has to be protected
at all costs oh he is the sweetest but
everybody's been saying the Ali
character is the nicest character what
are people saying for the most famous
Cameron
yeah few said Greg a few said Greg it's
sort of the toss-up mean to Jennifer
it's like how can you be mean to
Jennifer
yeah you know Cameron sweetheart it's
also so hot
oh my God
that leads me into my next question
because the two of you have chemistry
that I call it the non-chemistry
chemistry because this is the female
conundrum that he so brilliantly pointed
out in this females sometimes should be
with the nice guy but they're not
attracted to and then somebody else sets
their soul on fire so how did the two of
you Cameron how did the two of you
create the non-chemistry chemistry
wait say that again how did we you were
so you were as a cop like together
there's maybe a romance Brewing I think
you really want it and you're like he's
nice but I don't know if he's doing it
for me kind of things but you sort of
have that you have chemistry about not
having chemistry does that make sense
yeah you're like no not really I'm my
brain is a little fried so it's take me
a while to process this can
how'd you work together that's the
question
I think I think
the the moment where they meet by the
pool in episode one they have the most
chemistry and then every time they it's
like and the more she gets to actually
know that oh he's a really nice guy she
realizes this is not what I'm looking
for so the chemistry just starts to
dwindle yeah away like a like a candle
that's burning dimly morning hours and
there is a sadness to that too from the
Porsche perspective of like even though
she's
after this thing that's not him
um like maybe there is like a slight
subconscious awareness of like knowing
that if she just could give in to an
Alby of the world that things could be
really great and she could be supported
and things could be stable and she could
be treated well and she could be seen
and she you know but like yeah but you
can't force it
you know I think relationships are like
farting because if you force it it's
probably it right
you've been having such good ones today
not farts but sayings that was so good
it was the best thing I've ever heard in
any junket in my entire life
chips are like cards
yeah you could write White Lotus season
three
I am you just came up with that just now
that's so impressive wow it really is I
don't even know how to recover from that
I'm gonna I'm gonna follow up and ask
you a question there's a date in one of
the scenes about whether or not The
Godfather is the greatest American movie
of all time how what are your true
thoughts on The Godfather
um well I watched it for the first time
in Sicily with with Megan who plays
Daphne and I I mean I loved it and I was
going around telling everyone to watch
The Godfather because it's a great movie
they should call you know you should
give another chance I haven't seen it
you haven't seen it she hasn't given it
the full attention but I mean I do what
do I think the greatest American movie
ever made is inside out
yeah
Men in Black
pretty good film there's the Ted lasso
reference in the series have you watched
oh yeah I've seen the first series can't
wait for season three reference
like I don't watch that it's probably
too much fun for her character
she's like I don't I
um yeah it was cool seeing the Godfather
in this day and age I mean I think it I
think it definitely holds up so
how do you think could you sort of like
juxtapose for me like how does because
we love Jennifer and we always love
Tanya but how does Porsha see Tanya
versus how you see Jennifer how opposite
is that
oh yeah I would say
um totally opposite
um except for there is like a core
energy of this person that's just like
um just like
just this unexpected you really I don't
I literally every day I showed up to set
didn't know like what Jennifer was gonna
be like she's always gonna be Jennifer
and she's obviously a Charming kind
woman unlike Tanya but it's like she is
so unique and so unexpected and so like
uh
unique
um so that whole kind of quality core
quality uh I do think is similar and
probably why Jennifer makes these iconic
characters including Tanya um and
they're so really out there
but yeah I'm definitely I was never
annoyed at Jennifer and I think that
Porsha is
permanently annoyed at Tanya what do you
think the most White Lotus there's like
an energy about why Lotus gas is that
they can be very bougie what's the most
bougie Thing YouTube got to do in Italy
because I saw on your Instagram
something about Big Mommy style
meatballs
is that is that bougie I mean
I mean I mean you were in Italy yeah
that makes it yeah I loved going I loved
the different you know differently
translated uh the menus over there
that's where we found our big meatballs
Mommy style uh I mean I tried to do
something bougie that backfired okay
literally backfired because Sergio there
we had this amazing masseuse over there
that Mike and Haley swore by there it
was the best best massage I've ever had
in my life I was like okay I'll get it
it was the worst massage it was 90
minutes of torture I think that Mike and
I are just those type of people that
like to like belt different it's deep in
there you kind of like feel like it
hurts I mean and you're not like that
maybe I'm crazy but I'm like feeling a
fingernail in my back when I'm getting a
massage but you have to each their own I
guess what's your bougiest moment
um
man
I don't know well I tried to bring us to
a strip club but I guess that's not
really bougie to begin with and the
strip club we went to was the opposite
of bougie yeah a lot of bougie
backfiring I'd say we tried but yeah I
mean just the very fact I really wanted
to see like Sicilian strippers he did
and I did
I mean just staying at the Four Seasons
is you know incredibly bougie I think I
didn't stay there right
I just wanted to inform you that my good
friends here they're going to be
visiting me this week coming and going
they come
see so congratulations on being a part
of the White Lotus season two
um I first wanted to ask you I saw
something on your Instagram about how
when you got the role I think before you
started filming you couldn't sleep I
couldn't sleep tell me why and how and
how did you overcome that and how was
the first day I've said
uh yes because because I was too scared
there was too much pressure on this role
because in the previous season Murray
Bartlett had the Drone and Unforgettable
character and
so of course I felt this pressure and I
didn't want to disappoint anybody I felt
it was big expectations about this role
and so I just simply couldn't sleep and
in those days Murray Bartlett won the
critics award like everybody was I was I
was reading articles about how genius he
was and I thought
I would like to go back in the womb of
my mom you know to ask for some
protection I was feeling really and in
fact it's my mom that one day while I
was crying at the phone with her because
I was too scared she said now you stop
it you just do your job this is your
life you love it so much stop it with
this fear and actually she helped me and
um and then I started to
sky on the roll you know I started to
can I say that I don't know and I'm
making it up yeah sorry skiing like I
started to really to really like
Valentina became alive and
um yes and I started to sleep and I was
feeling more comfortable also because
when you don't sleep you feel that your
face is changing like the eyes are here
like the nose goes bigger
they couldn't even look closer yes I
thought oh my God I'm a monster because
like what happened to you you're like
your eye is over here
you like me so much perfect you're like
perfectly composed and giving the wave
and welcoming everybody in for the two
of you you created such a friendship on
screen that I believe that the two of
you are friends like have always been
friends for like since you were children
and even on somebody's Instagram you
were dressed the same in one of your
shots so can you talk about creating
that relationship so that on screen we
believe that yeah
um we met 10 years ago oh you did yeah
we did so it's crazy that you saw that
I'm so glad wow but we met 10 years ago
but we just met and we didn't really
know each other but then
um during the self-tay process uh we
helped each other to do the the
auditions yeah exactly she called me and
she said like I need somebody to help me
can you and I said wait I've done this
and let's let's do it and we had so much
fun and then we actually because we
worked together in another Italian
series and then but I think and we we
became friends but I think that this
this show is what uh is what brought us
closer we were really close and like we
became yeah and I'm wondering for all
three of you how does working on the set
of an American TV show like in terms of
your acting
is it any different from an Italian show
is it bigger is it smaller is it is
there are there differences as actresses
there is a big difference like of course
it's bigger like Italian is a very small
market so
um everything is smaller
and also the method of acting is totally
different so to be honest I felt finally
this is my cup of tea because all my
life I've been studying with the
American acting coaches while in Italy
there is not this school and
to be honest
most of Italian actor they fake like
it's that tradition of pretending not
leaving the experience of the character
so that to me was a huge difference
totally so I could be an actress in
Italy
definitely I mean of course there are so
many talented actors of course I'm not
talking about there are amazing actors
but the method of working is different
the approach is different were you
singing live was that live or was it
recorded no no it was live it was live
yeah yeah but yeah because Mike wanted
to be like he said yeah I wanted to be
real and I said how real because I am
scared like I'm not as perfect but then
yeah we we did it live and it was
exciting yeah I saw I know it's on your
Instagram but I want to know for all of
you because you posted a video when
Jennifer won her Emmy and you posted a
video of Michael and Murray together and
then
um somebody I think the cast was like
freestyling so just your experiences
maybe you can start first your
experiences working with these actors
that we know in love in America and sort
of behind the scenes
it was a um a huge Human Experience for
me
um
I think this is the the main
um
I think that being all together in this
little town out of season in this hotel
really helped our relationships to
develop so much and the fact that we
were so many times having dinner
together we celebrated our birthdays
together
so there are some Unforgettable moments
like for example I have
um a memory about Michael imperiali
uh before starting the series like just
the day before I had a kind of panic
attack and he was there and I started to
cry and tremble everything
and I will never forget his behavior
like I didn't know him and he took me in
in his arm and he said I know what you
feel because I feel the same I'm scared
as you are and I will cover your back
you can count on me and you know that
from that moment I felt home I felt I
can count on this human being and he was
he was a reference to me on set I I kept
going to to him and and then actually
also with other people these things
happened in a very beautiful way and
even in these days that we are meeting
again it's such a beautiful feeling yes
yeah they said it all
um for me it was mainly like Aubrey
Plaza I love her like what what's
happening it's like Michael Imperioli
Murray Abram and all these amazing
artists and I'm like am I actually like
how am I supposed to relate to these
people like am I the same like I I don't
know and I had all my friends from Italy
going
and all the actors Michael imperiali and
it's just it's crazy you know because
from one day to another you just throw
into a project and all the the actors
and actresses that you love they work
with you
something that does not happen every day
so I I think I think it was it was just
incredible and like to just be inspired
by by their talent and I have to say
that I fall in love with Jennifer
Coolidge she's one of the best human
beings I've ever met in my entire life
and I feel that she really is inside my
heart forever I adore her she's
she's incredible